[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisir avec de la
lecture cet été les médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines participent à
l'action nationale partir en livre pour
en parler avec nous Marie-Pierre Caruel
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes la
responsable politique d'action
culturelle pour le réseau des
médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines première
question c'est quoi l'événement partir
en livre alors partir en livre comme
vous l'avez dit c'est un événement
national qui est organisé par le Centre
national du livre surtout le territoire
français et par le salon du livre
jeunesse de Montreuil donc les experts
de la littérature jeunesse et cette
année donc ils ont choisi comme
thématiques la liberté nous avons pris
quelques libertés avec la liberté cet
investissement
et donc nous avons choisi de
proposer plutôt des activités autour de
l'arbre du vivant voilà et comme c'est
ce qui intéresse le plus les jeunes mais
en fait c'est un événement qui est
destiné à être proposé hors les murs des
médiathèques donc dans les parcs les
jardins sur les plages liées en général
aux activités des villes toutes les
quartiers d'été on organise ces journées
en lien avec les communes donc sur leurs
événements festifs de l'été et donc il y
a beaucoup de parcs enfin il y a
beaucoup de parcs beaucoup de jardins et
la thématique de l'arbre et de la nature
se prêtait bien au sujet et alors cette
année on a une héroïne super qui nous
accompagne pour partir en livre fichiers
du parti en livre 2023 donc c'est mortel
Adèle donc une héroïne que les enfants
apprécient beaucoup et des activités
alors on a prévu autour de mortelle
Adèle déjà de pouvoir lire les livres
dans ce qu'on propose sur chaque action
un espace lecture donc avec toute la
collection de mortelle qui sera à
disposition alors on peut trouver des
enfants peuvent trouver aussi des cartes
à colorier les cartes postales que pour
envoyer alors
envoyer des cartes postales ils peuvent
aussi trouver sur le portail des
médiathèques une page dédiée à partir en
livre à l'événement donc ou sur lequel
on peut trouver donc le programme
complet qui se déroule donc sur les 12
communes de 50 ans en Yvelines sans
exception
le programme une affiche à colorier des
sélections de lecture autour de la
liberté un par exemple une sélection de
musique aussi autour de puisqu'on a des
ressources en ligne sur le portail donc
autour de moi alors des lectures autour
de la liberté et puis on va vous y
proposer des lectures pour l'été enfin
différentes sélections proposées par les
bibliothèques donc ça c'est sur le et
justement en termes de lecture c'est
assez varié il y a un thème en
particulier où il y en a vraiment pour
tous les goûts alors on a privilégié la
thématique de la liberté au moins pas
sur la proposition artistique
d'animation mais sur le sur les
sélections de livres
cette sélection justement vous pouvez
nous en donner peut-être que les
sélections moi-même je ne les ai pas
préparés donc je voudrais pas vous dire
des bêtises
à découvrir voilà j'invite tout le tout
public à se rendre sur le portail donc
i- médiathèque.fr le site pour en savoir
plus qui s'affiche à l'écran pourquoi
faire sortir les livres des médiathèques
c'est pour aller plus facilement vers
les jeunes alors l'idée c'est de
proposer effectivement des activités ou
les publics se trouvent pendant l'été et
les médiathèques m'ont sont grandes
ouvertes alors il y a des petits
réductions de d'ouverture donc pour info
pareil sur le site
on peut trouver les horaires d'ouverture
proposé en juillet août
pour la lecture vis-à-vis des jeunes ils
lisent encore
les jeunes lisent toujours mais les
effectivement la lecture c'est quand
même un sujet
passif évident alors tout est lecture
quand on est quand on utilise un
smartphone on lit aussi la lecture
change la lecture est plus de leur du
zapping peut-être qu'on lit moins de
roulement et encore il y a des il y a
beaucoup de jeunes qui s'y trouvent le
bon genre le bon style qui leur convient
peuvent dévorer des livres donc les
jeunes continuent à lire ils lisent
différemment je pense que c'est plutôt
ça la tendance actuelle ils disent
différemment et du coup vous vous
adaptez en sortant ces livres des
médiathèques vous pensez que ça va aussi
attirer des lecteurs qui ne se
connaissent pas encore alors
effectivement je pense que les
médiathèques sont quand même des lieux
dans lesquels il faut avoir la volonté
de se rendre et c'est pas c'est
quelquefois c'est aussi
peut-être trop souvent associ à l'école
bibliothèque école il y a un lien assez
familier en tout cas dans l'esprit des
familles des parents très scolaires
alors qu'on n'est pas du tout sur les
mêmes enjeux on est on est là pour
proposer toutes sortes de de lecture de
mais aussi de la musique du cinéma déjà
on a on a différents supports et puis on
est là pour la lecture plaisir et pas
pour apprendre à lire ou voilà d'être
vraiment sur le versant loisir beaucoup
plus et donc or les murs effectivement
or les murs on espère et on souhaite
très vivement pouvoir trouver des
publics qui naturellement n'iraient pas
en médiathèque alors au cours de
l'événement les enfants seront aussi
conviés à participer à une oeuvre
collective il y aura une peintre un
compteur et un botaniste est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus voilà alors le
projet fil rouge de cet été de partir en
livre c'est la création d'une oeuvre
collective à partir d'ateliers qui vont
être réalisés sur les 12 communes
animé donc par une peintre illustratrice
et qui s'appelle Éloïse Robin qui fait
un travail magnifique je vous invite
vraiment à découvrir l'album qu'elle a
illustré
écrit par comment il s'appelle Laurent à
vélo donc qui est à la fois botaniste et
compteur c'est la même personne donc il
est botaniste au Muséum d'histoire
naturelle et il est également compteur
et donc il va animer des ateliers autour
des arbres de l'arbre frères autour de
la notion de de du calendrier celtique
c'est-à-dire que dans le calendrier
celtique en fonction de sa date de
naissance on a la correspondance d'un
arbre qui nous qui correspond à notre
personnalité à nos valeurs et donc
chaque participant aux ateliers sera
invité à trouver son arbre frère déjà
après à le concevoir au niveau graphique
à le découper et sur chaque ville à
partir de tous ces arbres ira création
d'une petite forêt suspendue ce serait
une espèce de mobile suspendue et après
à la suite de tous ces ateliers
rendez-vous le 30 septembre à la galerie
la galerie d'exposition de la ville de
Guyancourt pour découvrir
tous ces toutes ces créations et cette
création collective donc là il y aura
vraiment un moment festif avec une
déambulation du compteur qui aura
réalisé pendant les ateliers alors soit
des haïku il y aura peut-être écrit des
haïku suivant son inspiration soit des
haïku soit des alors des high pousse ce
sont de cours poèmes
je me sens que c'est 4 vers il y a des
contraintes très très spéciales
d'origine c'est sa partie à la culture
japonaise et c'est en général pour
traduire un sentiment l'impression du
moment voilà suivant une forme
stylistique assez
déterminée bien rendez-vous le 30
septembre alors merci beaucoup
Marie-Pierre careuelle d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en plateau alors pour
rappel partir en livre c'est jusqu'au
1er septembre dans toutes les
médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous
retrouverez toutes les informations sur
le site Internet qui s'affiche sur votre
écran